[Captions by Y Translator]
How much electric
charge can you get
from a Van de Graaff generator?
And if you let
that charge build-up,
what's it going to do
when it starts shocking stuff?
[Music]
This is a Van
de Graaff generator.
Now this is not one
that we built,
although that may be
a future project.
So this is one that we
just bought online,
and we're going to have some fun
experimenting with it today.
For those of you who don't know,
a Van de Graaff
generator is something
that lets you use
static electricity to build
up some surprisingly
large electric charges.
The construction
is pretty basic.
Let's go over that.
First of all,
we have this over here.
This is just a wheel.
When we turn this wheel
with its handle over here,
it twists this smaller wheel,
and this smaller wheel is
what's actually doing
the important stuff.
As you can see,
this smaller wheel is
on a gear attached
to this white rod in here.
So when I turn that wheel,
that white rod starts spinning.
Attached onto that rod
is this thick rubber band.
As it twists,
that rubber band goes up.
It's going past this right here.
This is an electrode
in the shape of sort of a comb.
You can see
that it's got all
of these little teeth
that are metal,
and it's just being held
on this plastic sheet,
and that's just hold it
where it's supposed to go.
Up here at the top
our rubber band goes
around a clear rod,
and there is a second comb.
This comb is attached
to this top piece,
which is a metal plate,
which has this connecting
point up at the top.
That as you can see fits nicely
into this dome shaped bell.
Turning this wheel,
and spinning all
of the moving pieces
in here starts generating
static electricity.
With our two combs,
one of the top,
one on the bottom
that's attached to this bell,
all of the electricity
gets built up
in this metal partial sphere.
It's not a perfect sphere,
but it's generally ball-shaped.
These things are really cool
because although they
have pretty low current,
they can have
extremely high voltage.
These desktop models
can probably generate at
least a hundred thousand volts.
So with all of that,
the principal is pretty simple.
You turn this wheel down here,
and it generates
static electricity up top,
which you can then sometimes
direct towards other things.
Or you can just
touch it, like this.
[Music]
Or you can just put your hands
near it like this.
This is an interesting
phenomenon to try
and catch on camera,
because it can
easily be so quick
that it happens in between
the frames of our camera.
While filming this,
it's maybe one in 10
of the sparks is actually
getting caught on camera,
which means I just had
to shock my hand quite a bit,
but that's what happens
when you're playing is
Van de Graaff generator.
So you're going to get zapped.
I can also try
and make this sparks jump
from our large ball
to this smaller ball over here.
I think probably most people
have tried rubbing
a balloon in their hair
until it builds up
a static charge to see and stick
to the walls and stuff.
Well, we have a sort
of amplified version
of that here.
Just gonna take our balloon.
We're going to start cranking,
see what happens.
[Music]
That was like one rotation.
How far away I can get
and still had it get pulled in?
[Music]
So the balloon sticks,
and then once I discharge it,
the balloon just
drops right down.
One of the best ways
to really show off
the effect is to let it run
through your hair a little bit,
and I don't have a ton of hair,
but this should still
be fun to watch.
[Music]
It also likes to jump the bridge
through the air into your hair
really easily so...
It's quite a big jolt
onto my scalp.
[Music]
So you can see
how it's transferring
the sparks over to my hand.
It zaps it pretty well.
At least sometimes
you can see it.
But there's another way
you can do this as well,
and that's instead of causing
sparks to jump little by little,
you can build the charge up,
not just in the bell,
not just in this metal bell,
but actually in myself.
So if I have my hand
on the bell directly,
and I'm insulated
from the ground,
which I'm doing right now
by wearing my high
quality Proto putty shoes.
It seems a very good insulators.
I am insulated.
However, the frame
of this bench is not.
So if I put my hand on here,
and turn the wheel a little bit,
I'll start building up a charge
that will then discharged
as soon as I touch
the edge of that bench.
It can be a big discharge.
Oh!
Man, like you do
these ones right here,
and you only feel it about
as far as your knuckle.
But when I do it like this,
my body can hold so
much more charge.
I feel it all the way
through my arm,
and my whole body
jumps involuntarily.
Now, something else I
think is pretty interesting,
and I discovered this
while playing around
with the Van de Graaff
generator earlier today.
If I take this powerful magnet,
and I put it near the bell,
I'm now off the ground again.
I'm in both of my rubber shoes.
If I turn the wheel
with the magnet near the bell,
there's no sparking.
There's no shocking,
and it doesn't seem
like it's doing anything at all.
But if I touch
the metal railing...
It gives me a jolt.
So it's charging
me up the same way
as if I have my hand
on the bell by putting
the magnet near the bell.
So I have not yet had
time to do research
into exactly what is happening.
But it appears
that the electric field
generated by our Van de
Graaff generator is somehow
using the magnetic field
to transfer the electricity
into me without
having any sparks.
That's pretty cool.
I had my camera man
turning the crank,
and I was building
up so much charge
that it was actually
shocking me through my feet,
through the Proto putty shoes
into the floor.
And so now, I'm standing
on a wooden board to see
if that offers
even more insulation.
All right, charge me up.
[Music]
I can feel it.
All my arm hairs
are just getting tingly.
[Music]
Now, I'm going to
attack my cameraman.
Oh, very quickly
building up charge.
I feel like Thor,
and I want to hammer.
So that works too.
All right here goes.
This is scary.
Holy cow.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that was crazy.
Okay.
We're getting some crazy
big shocks by having
my cameraman turn this
while I'm really well insulated.
So we have this little
gallium metal cast Lego figure,
and I want to see
if we can shock that.
Okay, so this is
kind of weird like,
if I go over here
on the shelf,
I get a giant zap.
But if I go
to the gallium figure,
it just makes
a hissing, fizzing sound.
Sounds a lot like Tesla coil.
So that just zapped me,
but it's a pretty
small zap compared
to the charge up for a bit.
[Music]
We were trying to grab
some footage of shocking
a small gallium cast Lego man,
because we thought it would be
fun to make me look like Thor.
But we discovered
that something about
the gallium is causing
some weird things to happen.
Rather than getting shocked
with a long arc of electricity,
it actually started
emitting plasma out
of the Lego man's head.
I could smell the ozone,
and if I got close enough,
I could see
the tiny purple sparks.
It was really hard to capture
on a regular camera,
but we did use a modified GoPro
with a zoom lens added
that didn't have
an infrared filter,
and we were able to see
it a little bit more.
Strangely, through the
little gallium man,
while it was arcing plasma like that,
the actual electrical
discharge was very small.
Touching the metal rim
of the workbench gave
me a huge jolt and caused
a spark several inches long
that was very visible.
If I touch the gallium Lego man,
rather than the
really big jolt,
it was just a pretty small one.
Similar to when I
was putting my knuckles close
to the bell at the beginning.
One of the most popular
projects we have ever had
on our channel is showing
how to build a laser blowgun,
and we have turned that
into a kit that you can order,
and if you act quickly,
you can still get it
in time for Christmas.
That kit comes with everything
you could possibly need.
We have got a glue gun,
PVC pipes, decals, a laser,
everything that you need for
your own backyard adventures.
So my initial
reaction the second
that we open those kits was just
how much we provided for you.
It's nearly everything
that you need,
and it's amazing quality.
It's really fun.
We didn't help plan this out.
So when we opened,
it really was just
like us getting the kit
for the first time.
I was especially impressed
that it comes like with a glue
gun and glue sticks and stuff.
I was not expecting that.
Everything you need,
it takes probably what,
15 to 30 minutes depending
how quickly were working to get
your blow gun up and ready,
and then maybe a little bit
longer if you're trying
to fine-tune the laser,
which it even comes
with everything for that.
Like to zero in that laser
so it's perfectly accurate.
It worked crazy well.
I also really like the fact that
although it comes
with the supplies
and equipment to make
the nail darts,
the paper cone at the back.
It's like the perfect size
that you can use
in miniature marshmallows,
and so you can have
like a laser assisted
marshmallow blow gun fight.
Or blowgun marshmallow wars
in your kitchen or studio.
There might still be
marshmallows all over the place.
Possible.
Just maybe.
We've got a couple
hundred in stock,
but we do expect
them to go fast.
So if you want for yourself,
or a friend or family member,
now is the time to get it.
If you guys decide to go all out
and bedazzle one
of these things,
or just make it look really
really cool, we want to see.
Send us pictures.
There's lots of ways
you can decorate.
You can use paint,
you can use tape.
I guess you
could use a bedazzler,
if you really want gems and--
What is the bedazzler?
It puts like rhinestones on it.
I don't know
if it works on PVC,
but someone should figure out
how to make that work.
Anyway, lots of ways to make
this blowgun your own,
modifying what we
have in the kit.
Very cool stuff.
The link for one of these kits
is in the description.
Have fun.
Be safe.
Build something cool.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end.
We've always got more
for you see.
That box up at the top
will take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe to our channel.
That way you never miss
out on our video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.